dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly effective creating
the photorealistic image with fur and
hair is hard it is typically done by
using light simulation programs where we
use the laws of physics to simulate the
path of millions and millions of light
rays and they bounce off of different
objects in the scene this typically
takes from minutes to hours if we are
lucky however in the presence of
materials like hair and fur this problem
becomes even more difficult because fur
fibers have inner scattering media this
means that we not only have to bounce
these rays off of the surface of objects
but also have to simulate how light is
transmitted between these inner layers
and initially we start out with a noisy
image and this noise gets slowly
eliminated as we compute more and more
rays for the simulation FPP means
samples per pixel which is the number of
rays we compute for each pixel in our
image and you can see that with previous
techniques using 256 samples per pixel
leads to a very noisy image and we need
to spend significantly more time to
obtain a clear converged image and this
new technique enables us to get the most
out of our samples and if we render an
image with 256 SPP we get a roughly
equivalent quality to a previous
technique using around six times as many
samples if we have a film studio and
someone walked up on us and said that we
can render the next guardians of the
galaxy film six times cheaper would
surely be all over it this would save us
millions of dollars the main selling
point is that this work introduces a
multi scale model for rendering hair and
fur this means that it computes near and
far field scattering separately the far
field scattering model contains
simplifications which means that it's
way faster to compute this
simplification is sufficient if we look
at the model from afar or we look
closely at the hair model that is way
thinner than human hair strands the
near-field model is more faithful to
reality but also more expensive to
compute and the final most important
puzzle piece is stitching together the
two whenever we can get away with it
we
should use the far-field model and
compute the expensive near-field model
only when it makes a difference visually
and one more thing and these hamsters
get closer or further away from the
camera we need to make sure that there
is no annoying jump when we are
switching models and as you can see the
animations are buttery smooth and when
we look at it we see beautiful rendered
images and if we didn't know a bit about
the theory we would have no idea about
the multi scale wizardry under the hood
excellent work the paper also contains a
set of decking positions for different
light paths for instance here you can
see a fully rendered image on the left
and different combinations of light
reflection and transmission events for
instance R stands for one light
reflection TT for two transmission
events and so on the s in the
superscript denotes light scattering
events adding up all the possible
combinations of these T's and ours we
get the photorealistic image on the Left
that's really cool loving it if you
would like to learn more about light
simulations and holding a full master
level course on it at the Technical
University of Vienna and the entirety of
this course is available free of charge
for everyone I got some feedback from
you fellow scholars that you watched it
and they enjoyed it quite a bit give it
a go as always the details are available
in the video description
thanks for watching and for your
generous support now see you next time
[Music]